thank you commissioner adam silver for
making the the announcement today uh
question for you
giannis uh when as you
sit in athens greece and it's nine
o'clock at night there
uh and i know you've been with your
family there you're on vacation
what does it mean to you to receive this
in the place where you first picked up a
basketball
it means a lot uh obviously uh this is
where i started playing basketball
um can you guys hear me
yeah go ahead so it means a lot to me
this is where i started playing
basketball uh
it feels it feels good to uh you know
get this award
announced when i'm back home okay
nothing's pissed
uh first of all you know thank god i
always thank god
for giving me the opportunity to do what
i love go out there and
play basketball and put me in the right
position to be successful
i want to thank my family my brothers
my mother my dad my significant other
my son for keeping me uh especially
myself for keeping me
up late at night and uh forcing me to
study the game more and now watch tape
i want to thank my teammates and my team
maybe for listening up every single
night
and going out there and uh giving
everything they got with me
this award would not be possible without
them always good to remember that
significant other giannis that was that
was very well done
if you leave the significant other out
you're going to you're going to hear
about it
yeah when i think about players who have
done what you've done this year not only
winning the mvp now in back-to-back
years
but to be the defensive player of the
year and the mvp
and you look at michael jordan and akeem
olajuwon so what does it mean to you
to join that group today
oh man just all-time great players
obviously michael jordan one of the best
players to ever done it
he's not the best uh i came
a guy that i look up to uh
he came from where i'm from nigeria from
just being in the same conversation you
know it's a great complaint but you know
i have a lot of work to do
i got to keep getting better my mindset
never going to change
but just being in that conversation in
the same centers with them that
that means a lot to me and it wouldn't
be possible without hard work so i just
gotta
focus what i do best which is you know
keep working hard
yeah you you talk about getting better
and i look at your career numbers
and in every season your points and
rebounds
have increased just from scoring from 7
to 13 to 17 to 23 to 27 to 28
to just under 30 this season so what is
it that you do
in between seasons in the off season
to improve your game
i tried to start the game try to spend
as much time as i can in the gym
trying to sharpen my tools just
know the game obviously as you grow
older you get more mature
you can play the game better but at the
end of the day you got to put as many
hours
as you can in to work in a jump shot to
work on your post moves to work on your
passive
uh and it's something i love to do i
always love to get in the gym
work hard for a summer two three months
and then in the season see the results
that of all the work i did
and i it's something that excites me
something that motivates me and
some that i always look forward to every
uh every summer
yes i did a series of interviews during
the hiatus before play began with a
number of
players around the nba and including
dirk nowitzki and it was interesting
when i talked to dirk about his mvp
season it had come in the same year that
his team had been knocked out of the
playoffs early and he said it was
it was kind of a strange feeling to get
the award and then still
feel the disappointment of of the
playoffs and i'm not saying that's the
way you have to feel but how do you
resolve those two feelings going on
right now with you
obviously i would love to be still in
the bubble keep playing games being the
second spanish you know fighting to uh
get opportunity to play in the finals
uh but at the end of the day you know uh
awards award
i'm extremely blessed where i
came from from where i started and where
i am right now it's been a long journey
and uh you know the people that know me
the people that know my story
you can never take these moments for
granted you know you can never take this
moment
for granted so obviously i'm
disappointed for not being uh
able to uh help my team go to the uh
to the third round but at the end of the
day i know that i
keep getting better i gotta keep making
my team uh uh
improved but uh i cannot i cannot take
uh that feeling cannot take away nothing
from this award
you know i work extremely hard uh my
teammates helped me
the coaching staff the fans supported me
all
season long to be able to be in this
position
i'm happy for this i'm happy for this
award but uh i
want more uh as i said last year my dad
told me um
always want more but never be greedy um
same thing you know obviously i'm very
grateful this opportunity for this
moment but
i got to keep getting better i want to
be a champion i want
when i'm done with this game to be
extremely proud and happy for whatever i
accomplish
and you know the next generation can
take pics from my game and uh
the next generation can watch me playing
guys who want to
you know look up to me um the same way i
look up to
hakeem magic johnson other great players
i played this game
so it goes back to i got to get better
but
you know i want more i want to be a
champion and i want
i want more i want to always be better i
know the fans in milwaukee are
are thrilled along with you to get this
mvp award again and i know you
you put on social media the other day a
thanks to the fans in milwaukee for
their
non-stop support and you look forward to
to the coming season
but look they're all wondering the same
thing basketball fans are all wondering
and that's
a long-term future in milwaukee what can
you what can you tell me at this point i
know you had
lunch with the executives and you and
you know as the three hours worth i mean
what's the next step and
how do you view a possible long-term
extension or signing a super max and
staying
in milwaukee
obviously right now i'm just trying to
focus on my family
you know i was in the bubble for two
months almost uh
tried to spend as much time as i can
with them i'm back in greece
now i'm able to see my mom and my older
brother
i'm not trying to think about it as much
and what i'm going to do next uh but one
thing that i know that i'm going to do
next that i'm going to keep
i'm going to get better and when the
time comes that
we're going to talk about contact and
we're going to talk about longer
you know long-term future with milwaukee
uh
that's gonna be that time i'm gonna be
that moment but i'd never do that i want
to get
keep getting better i want to focus on
my family uh obviously i had the great
meeting with uh
the owners talk about the team talk
about what went wrong what can we
improve and
um as long as everybody's in the same
page and as long as
everybody is fighting for the same thing
not fighting every single day
which is to be a champion
i don't see that i don't see you know
why not been working for the next
15 years uh i i kind of expected
that answer at this stage of how things
are going uh
uh with the milwaukee bucks and and
bottom line today is this
congratulations on
back to back mvp award so i guess last
year when you said you can't call me mvp
until i've done it twice now we can call
you the mvp huh
no no not not yet uh now yeah i got to
set a goal which i don't know the goal
what the goal is right now
actually i know what the goal is don't
don't call me everybody don't come into
touch
until i'm i'm a champion